you know the junior track of the senior
tracker very different and it's
intentional you know in the junior year
we want to develop that master student
they do classes in conceptual
mathematics which is really trying to
strengthen their algebra skills as well
as a physics readiness class they also
take a class called becoming a master
student which really helps with their
study skills and their study techniques
in the senior curriculum we're moving on
to more college readiness and college
credit bearing classes so our seniors
will take a precalculus or calculus
class I'm depending on which one they
test into and these are Carnegie Mellon
credit-bearing classes the seniors also
take an English class which helps them
to begin writing their college
application essay we've heard a lot of
feedback from students that that's been
a great experience for them and leaving
here after the six weeks and having
three prepared essays ready to go for
the college applications all students
take an essay tea preparation class
because we know some of the gatekeepers
in getting into highly selective
universities rs80 scores
in the afternoon from three to five
every day they do engineering and
science projects they've done things in
biology that done things a music
engineering rocket engineering tissue
engineering so really some cutting-edge
interesting things that they can get
their hands on and really try out
from day one when students check in they
hear about what's called the Sam's
family community is very important to us
we want to see the students succeed as a
group we have what's called family
meetings in which the RAS coordinate
sitting down and talking with the
students about just a variety of issues
it's the chance for them to have a big
brother or big sister here at Carnegie
Mellon and talk with them about the
college experience and how to sort of
prepare for that the Sam's family is
very important to in the classroom
aspect because you know if a student is
doing very well in physics and can
master physics but may not be that
strong in algebra you know there's ways
to help each other
I'm a facebook group usually every year
is created for the sams year and
students joined that and they just talk
about when they get home sort of how
they miss everybody and what's going on
but then throughout the year there you
know starting to begin to talk about
what what college are you looking at
applying and where will you be visiting
because maybe I could visit the same
time and we can get together so you
start to see these many reunions pop up
all over the country and we see that
family aspect really being cultivated
even after they leave the campus which
is a great feeling you know when when
Carnegie Mellon does its visit weekends
and the celebration of diversity
weekends normally there's a numerous
amount of Sam students that come here
and you know it gives them a chance to
reunite with their Sam's family but also
get a good look at Carnegie Mellon
during the academic year